greetings to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happening now is brought to you
by zip recruiter you know how
challenging it is to hire some money now
ours is to find a qualified candidate
takes a long time and a lot of
applicants but with zip recruiter it's
an easy peasy
working a URL once and at the beginning
ha listen all I want to say is this
hiring used to be hard multiple job
sites tax a resume a confusing review
process but today hiring can be easy and
you have to go to one place to get it
done you ready zip recruited doc Tom
that's it and that's that
do yourself a favor they're the smartest
way to hire so right now the church
family can get zip recruited you could
try it right now for free
and this is exclusive address web
address ready
zip recruited comm / church that's the
zip recruiter comm slash church zip
recruiter dot-com / CH you are CH that's
if you want to hire the tip top people
in the industry the church is also
brought to you by audits listen you fly
your travel you lifting weights you need
your supplement you need your protein
pilot island is the way to go
go down at that calm right now on press
ENTER CH BAM and get 10% off mean
deliver it right to your crib you
understand me that's stress how we do it
leak kick this love a [ __ ] meal man
are you [ __ ] kidding me right show me
where the [ __ ] you been
we took the week off it's the fourth of
July we're hanging out with bubbles
Gwinnett signing the Declaration of
Independence we said [ __ ] it I did Rogan
wins that's all you need
I want to walk with my brother brother
someone that welcome [ __ ] Lisa yeah
who's bubbles Gwinnett bubbles gonna
sign the Declaration of Independence I
grew up with his [ __ ] great
representative that's a real name
yeah bubbles were Michael that always
tommy is a legit I don't [ __ ] know
anyone who gives a [ __ ] I don't know
yeah he was at the Continental Congress
Lea didn't know your [ __ ] history I'm
sorry
bubbles before that I hope you had a
happy 4th I hope your families are back
guess what you're back and there's the
second half of the and this what [ __ ]
matters we went through the first half a
year we're ready for y'all start break
after the all-star break the year gets
real [ __ ] you're a month away from kids
going back to school pencil sharpeners
then you got Halloween and you got a
[ __ ] big turkey that's been kicked in
the fence for the last [ __ ] year cuz
I don't know about you I like Turkey it
gets kicked in the [ __ ] head oh my
and then you got the holidays then you
got Hanukkah and then got New Year's and
then he had another year oh you're
[ __ ] and you get older so this is it
[ __ ] we're in the final stretch right
now it's the last six months of the
[ __ ] year [ __ ] goals it was one
[ __ ] 17 on [ __ ] Friday I got sick
Friday there's at five o'clock I said
you know what let me go outside and
shadowboxing they're bored they weren't
at the house I'm sitting there for an
hour and a half I couldn't take a walk
with to having them in the yard let me
get something make it high yeah let me
just what the shadowbox low but get a
little vitamin D I suffered looking
hotter in like it's I'm blowing a
[ __ ] hot dick let me tell you
something I went back inside I said that
guys like an hour dizzy every time I got
up I swear that I go in the shower and
put it down to my nice kids and just let
it hit me [ __ ] that shadow went in
before unit oh my god that was hotter
than [ __ ] out there oh I finally saw the
video you were telling me about about
that poor girl who got caught on the
mountain what is it with fat people
don't what I'm running can you know the
hottest day let me do it right can't
stay in that place I can't stand that
[ __ ] people doing Tai Chi in the park
I use what I got here you know we all
got hit with different women I was just
thinking about your girlfriend today the
one that was in The Longest Yard yeah
yeah she's still around right yeah yeah
yeah she's still around she still killed
she still yeah well the family you know
I've known her my whole life so my our
parents still talk and everything yeah
okay Wow yeah but we all moved people to
check the mic and now we look at that
chicken we kind of like them we got that
they [ __ ] I moved out here for a
chick you moved I was in New York and
then I moved out for her yeah oh did you
yeah okay I didn't know that sorry nice
great kid she was she was booking a
comedy room for a while yes sir Bobo and
years ago but it's funny that she uh
you talk about your girl the one you
came out well I came out with a plane
like that so it's the third day yeah
she's like you're not gonna believe it
my friends told me that's a place to go
is right around the corner because we
lived on Hollywood Boulevard a block
away from the brand so you have to walk
up that block to go to Runyon Canyon
so Runyon Canyon is where you first get
here people know you have to go running
candidates it's great and you go uptown
when you first walk up there when I
first got here there was no Tai Chi
there was a bunch of jerk-offs doing
yoga and then there was a lunch table
there was two lunch tables and every day
at 9:30 those tables there were just two
rows of chicks of hot 22 27 year old
chick yeah there's a lot of broccoli a
more straight A's and the atz's makeup
on and they'd bring their sides that's
when you lose me sides of the sheets
that they give you right in the script
so they would go to this Park script in
a park they would go up there and these
girls would sit in a circle and I
remember that the girl I want what was
all these girls like I was a [ __ ]
cokehead I didn't want to go for a walk
but she was paying the rent
I wanna get a [ __ ] so you gotta go for
a walk you know Zion that's what happens
when you do when you [ __ ] a broker and
you live with it chase you want you to
go for a walk and either [ __ ] that's
the deal
so I would go to Grand Canyon and I
remember she was stretching when they
like the jerk-off that she was and I was
listening to the table of those girls
talking now listening like they were
just talking loud yeah and that's when
Titanic came up so Lee another capital
was out every night me too and [ __ ]
Mike Young with Mike Young spider-man to
dude you know my young was lighting
their cigarettes to shake you don't say
Mike Young was rubbing their shoulders
you did great gonna say like you did
great so [ __ ] that they would sit
there and talk about how they all went
to Leo's house and the other table they
were a little old they were all sucking
Jack Nicholson's dick oh my god we were
Jack's last night even hawkish my home
is so interesting and I think I want to
pick three time and it just wasn't for
me
and it's not like you know like the the
Chinese dudes doing the Taichi it's like
these weird white people doing this [ __ ]
like the one in San Francisco about just
like weird white yeah wanna be white
kids let me tell you that I care about
society type dude I had a guy when I
worked at the Cheesecake Factory come in
and this is just just the type of dude
like he was like a white you know the
white asian like the white people that
take over cult like they embrace
cultures I'm not doing them come on
yeah right it was just a jerk-off guy
and I just how I got written up at work
but real quick so he comes in he greets
me like you know with this like I'll
[ __ ] I'll smack you jerk-off so we're
running the specials I'm like yeah we
have an Asian ah he served a soy ginger
sauce that comes with Asian vegetables
right hand of God that he got offended
that I said Asian vegetables like like
he was just a [ __ ] like he'd like to
make me look like a dick he's like I'm
confused like what's an Asian vegetable
like I'm dead serious
so me being a [ __ ] smartass I made a
joke I said oh those are the sews thing
I got written up for this I go those are
the vegetables that are better educated
in a working harder and take any other
vegetables jobs yeah just as a joke he
would he went [ __ ] he was pissed I
offended powder white guy in know Pigman
in a kimono [ __ ]
it's it's but you he's the type of guy
that would be doing Tai Chi at the
[ __ ] in the park that right I got rid
of him a couple of times I wanted you
work at the Cheesecake Factory the way
this the first job I got when I came out
here I was delivering pizzas
I was working to cheesecake and I was
bouncing it I had a club in uh in 3rd
Street Promenade no one Wednesday nights
yeah and then I was getting up trying to
do stand-up in the meantime it's a
hustle man
what a [ __ ] hassle it is such a so I
was a grown man delivering pizzas not
even like a [ __ ] college kid like I
was like thirty in a [ __ ] 97 Ford
Escort you couldn't you couldn't make
[ __ ] left so it would stall out so I
would like if I had to go here and make
a right and then a right and then a
right then overshoot it and make another
right you know how shitty is it being
in your late 20s and early 30s we often
loser because I was the king of the
[ __ ] loses I deliver his [ __ ]
pizzas in the beginning of comedy I was
just sad but I didn't care because you
love because we love what we were doing
there was the excitement on at least for
me the obvious was being a criminal and
you know just being where we came from
that was the obvious at that point had
already done my time I had already
gotten out I said what can I do
I told him again that his family and
then I delivered Chinese food I sold
coke I mean I did a thousand things to
make ends meet like for me I come in at
cries but I wasn't a criminal and then
there's guys that are criminal like I
talked about it but we make mistakes
well people read my [ __ ] like when I go
to Canada they got everything but when
they read my stuff they're not like
going you know they're doing like yeah
you did that yeah he taught this story
about the night you turned yourself in
let me tell you something you have
[ __ ] up my head for the last six weeks
and said man I saw you because it was
funny you you I heard you say that thing
before but for some reason that night it
really took me by storm he has a joke
but he says that you know he grew up
that there was always those kids that
were always out and there's a one kid
that was outside all the [ __ ] 16 from
15 even a year before my mother died too
I left I was always that guy you were
always outside and it with me a girl
named Gina the guy named Mike there was
a dude named John they had to be a the
nine of us that had no curfew we had
families cuz even my mother was alive I
didn't have a curfew mmm my curfew was
after midnight I want you to call me
every hour on the hour let me know where
you are don't what time you gonna come
home yeah or what time you gonna call me
back that was a pretty cool curfew I'm
like how are we from 14 really you out
there that yeah from 14 12
all the 13 what time you coming home
yeah I mean that would watch how was
that without my mother I had to sneak
out I will crawl out the window or you
know pretend to be at a friend's house
which everybody did that but we were
outside my friend that had no
supervision we'd always just say we're
at his house
this kid was always [ __ ] outside why
didn't he have supervision the parents
didn't care the parents he was just he
just was out of control he was out of
control
yeah I had there had to be and it wasn't
really on no father no father it wasn't
that's a commonality
well that's commonality but it really
really like what the girl that was there
was a girl I hung with that was always
out her mother left when she was 10 just
got up and left and kept in touch of the
kids just told them the truth I don't
want to be a monk I don't want to be a
mom she moved to Vegas and dove
conscious so the dad worked nine to
[ __ ] night their dad ran a car
dealership and her and her brother were
out all the time and I also had a friend
who had more money than you and I Oh
ever [ __ ] see and his parents that's
it I had two friends like that this is
the other option to that coin too I had
two friends I had one friend that his
parents are doctors old his mom is dead
he would just go home to a box filled
with money right he would go upstairs
take money and take you out to dinner
himself to dinner so he bought his
friends or did you like the kid I really
liked him yeah well friends on Facebook
know he's a science teacher
I mean his parents ruined him because
they said them to be a doctor the
Dominican Republic and they kept selling
and tank random what oh my god so he was
done that's not cold and smoking weed he
I mean he's been a pilot like yeah when
people say oh you smoke this guy's ahead
nobody's a bigger head than this guy was
the first guy that took me into the city
to get weed mm-hmm like he was maybe 2
years older than me maybe a year or two
three tops he's the one that till we
took we took me to a church in the
village to cop there was a [ __ ]
Catholic Church in the village and on
Fridays downstairs the bingo hall the
priests who looked the other way
have my three bees come to my
neighborhood cop to you said right yes
doesn't know sake but say it yeah yeah I
used to come to per se I used to go I
didn't like the long drive you know you
don't want to drive with the drugs back
in the car yeah that's the thing like
yeah there was a Cuban doing him per se
but I used to go see for Coke and sure
like that but that's a 30-minute ride
hmm would you in a more City going right
to the Holland Tunnel yeah you know no
no in New York I grew up in North Bergen
so all I had to do was go over the
George Washington Bridge and come back
on the tunnel it's a 20 minute ride yeah
it's really a toy surprise just for you
to make a left go to 181 cop and just
stay on West Side Highway did you hit
the Lincoln watch tonight stop yeah 181
Autobahn all that all those Amsterdam
Autobahn you just walked down a neighbor
you don't have to go two feet somebody's
gonna be oh my god oh yeah right that
that was I think to me I love that Port
Authority like I realize Port Authority
on 42nd Street but for my taste for the
authority I'm gonna send me a street
they had TB after check downstairs
though the racing when you're just like
it's like 7-eleven if you really want to
[ __ ] feel good about your life we
should open up accommodation long track
betting White Castle in the Midwest you
how much money we'd make my nomination
White Castle now off-track betting oh my
god I saw some wild [ __ ] through the
years already
here's what's crazy that for a while I
was going all shy about it
really what do you know of our horses
don't know [ __ ] about as I used to those
days I would look at the program and I
would see there was a drug that you give
to a horse to stop it from bleeding from
the nose yeah there's a drunk that they
shoot them with and every time that the
horses we get shot with that it makes
them run faster so I would follow the
horses that would get shot with
I do people out the track my friend told
me how they fixed the Greyhounds they
that people were there so smart finish
tell me what you know I grew up at the
track I know the track backhand and
forehand like before my mom died I would
go to the track and then on there was
the name of the Pegasus of the Pegasus
yeah my friend God rest his soul
Vinnie Lynch was the head chef when in
fact bubbles one act brother bubbles
Burnett have great-great-grandson till
he had a Michael Burnett and his brother
was also a chef at the Pegasus you had a
word dinner jacket yeah it was like
guidances dude that was like a taste of
all the Jersey guys the Meadowlands in
1993 was as crazy as the place
as I've ever seen in my life li li you
will lost your money if I was it took
you through the melons how I had it in
93 I mean from cop and coke to getting
your dick sucked to smoking weed team
that red clam Charlie had with the
[ __ ] hard clams it tasted like a
[ __ ] hard clip like if the lady died
this year and stiff for four days that's
how hard the clip was when you hate
those clams at the at that [ __ ] track
there was a chick that died in the car
frozen and they was I don't want to give
her name got rest her soul we grew up
with her but she got the heavy is later
and she would walk around the track go
suck your dick for 10 bucks 15 bucks 20
bucks it's so different now I went to
the track with you and your family and
they have like kids oh yes this uh prj
do know that it's nice to Matt's very
but even the Meadowlands everything Lee
honestly everything's changed and yeah
how was the moment what was the last
time you talked to thousands I think
it's you gotta be 30 years for me I
can't lie to anybody I admit the mens
rea yeah it's gotta be it's even law
maybe 90 no no no I'm telling you 93 93
was the last time you were there I went
like ten I was there constantly because
I had moved back to do comedy well my
mother my stepfather used to go in the
80s you know but it's just
different how like when they were in
their 30s and like to what like I'm
dressed in a polo they would always wear
the suits all the guys you know you
didn't you didn't to them it was like a
night out to go to the Pegasus wouldn't
you believe how well that was a kid how
men would dress to hang out with other
men it's like they would get jazz up
matching socks have you seen the old
pictures of like a family park in the
suit you won't be caught dead you know
it was funny too like if you call them a
pimp or a gangster or something they
would they would get upset with that
like now it's a compliment even if they
were if he called him that I'm just
saying like nobody like that that
generation didn't like that they always
tried to appear to have more money I
remember a friend of mine came out to
this was years ago and Silverlake but
you know it's he was a real mechanic but
people that are blue-collar try to dress
like they have money and people that
have money try to dress like they're
[ __ ] blue-collar does that make sense
guys in a mechanic's shirt and a kid's
worth probably [ __ ] seven figures
well that's good my buddies you know was
a real mechanic and trying to dress like
he had money but that was always the
what you always see that was always the
mentality I was raised on yeah I was
raised around people that know I was
raised around people don't have money if
you saw them you go no no it's they
played the real guys the real guys
didn't need you to know that they had
money well but I was more I'm talking
more about like the fake blue-collar
[ __ ] that you see yeah yeah yeah well
here's a different list yeah
whatever you see here in this city in
Vista you've said it best
you said something I've never heard
before you said that this people's
attention hourly personnel as people
would care a character this is a town of
people personalities
eirick there is nothing well you know
character is what you do when nobody's
watching I'm a firm believer that
characters would absolutely when
nobody's watching you know I heard a
statement 15 years are gonna change my
life it changed my life the cocaine it
changed my life from being the [ __ ]
thief that I was
and it was don't let your character ruin
your destiny that is the most beautiful
words you'll ever hear in your life have
you taken the right way
don't let your character ruin your
destiny when I heard those words like in
2001 that changed me forever mm-hmm
because I had so many [ __ ] things I
wanted to do and I could not do being
the person that I was no there was no
way they tell you somebody mailed me a
[ __ ] a letter and there was a $20
bill and it's a counterfeit 20 old bill
they put it on my desk I don't know if
I'm putting my wallet on that hello if I
pass the $20 bill the last two days to
somebody somebody right now I can't find
the [ __ ] $20 bill I don't know if my
wife took it if my daughter took it
somebody pass a $20 bill but that's TV
you know it was fake or did they end the
letter it says it oh this is for you and
Lea blah blah blah it's a fake 20 I
looked at it was beautiful yeah remember
with the baby patty and yeah yeah
although you have to [ __ ] ring climb
up and shake them up I was gonna say I'd
fix the dogs okay yeah a Salt Lick them
before the Greyhounds does that mean
they get him thirsty and then they then
they have him drink a [ __ ] ton of water
before they run so the one that I told
me that I don't know that yeah the one
that they they that they want to weigh
him down so they would like if there's
seven eight nine dogs running they'll
Salt Lick like a double or like you know
that's why I saw Anna and I would go to
the track sometimes and we still go to
Highline in Florida a lot and go to the
Greyhounds but you see a dog just stop
and piss sometime now it makes sense
I used to go to Highline Connecticut
I've never went to one you crazy well
they just have the thing on the hand
right that's like a [ __ ] pool ball
man
but I used to buy coke at the Highland
place in Miami the guy would make me
meet him there Dan yeah I'll [ __ ] at 83
84 were you down that I was down there a
lot in 84 back and forth you have family
down there cuz you're Cuban yes yeah
family now they have a couple but my mom
wasn't a big Miami chick no no she said
that the Cubans in Miami was
still crying about when it happened that
she didn't have tell him for that [ __ ]
that she was time to have a way to stay
there was no worried about Cuba and all
this [ __ ] so that's why she went to
Jersey was more speed it was more faster
and whatnot because that's the I think
is it Union City into Philly's a second
biggest second second guess yeah I don't
know what it is now I don't know exactly
who in now you got you guys are so there
are we know we're still there but this
the block is a lot smaller so we drove
we were driving around everything's
closed man there's not even like my mom
with the Holy Rosary Academy all those
places are gone Holy Rosary Academy is
gone it's gone in Union City yeah so
Michaels is not God uh there's another
Catholic school that's gone to st.
Michael's even the city cannot me go
that's what you have to check it yeah
the old neighborhood everything's
changed we did a little tour of Jersey
City where my mom grew up and my you
know my grandparents were from there but
going back to that that was one of it I
have two friends I have you and my Duffy
then I love you to death
but because you say that [ __ ] it takes
me to a different place
what do you mean like I talked to Mike
once every 15 days me and my crew mates
in Colorado back in history Mike Duffy I
know Mike Duffy since she joined the
army and [ __ ] when they walk you know
that's how long I go back home my father
his uncle's know hmm whenever I talk to
me cuz you came out pretty good for a
kid that didn't have any supervision
every time he says it to me my [ __ ]
hairs on my chest and about but he's not
lying not he's not lying he's telling
you the truth and you know what 51 my
mother was alive in 1415 I still
remember coming home last Mac in the
face she game it was a week before she
died because I walked in the door like a
five in the morning I stopped calling it
too when I walked in the five and she
was right there she hit me and she goes
you know that's not gonna fly from now
on you have to call every hour on the
hour and all the last time I call
I felt like I was waking yeah because
don't wake me up wake me up I don't give
a [ __ ]
wake me up that's our deal and she was
like all I want the reason why I do this
with you if I don't do it the other way
it's because I don't understand that
this is what a man does a man tells his
wife what time he's gonna be back home
and that my wife doesn't give a [ __ ] if
you go out just tell her what time you
gonna be home and stick to that
commitment huh and you and your wife
will be fine and she and she like broke
it down for me by getting like she
slapped me at 6:00 in the morning and
then at 9:00 she came in there to talk
to me and this is just feel she was
telling me she goes this is what a man
does she won't get before you me grew up
I need to stick to that real that's that
wrong
she goes I wish that she goes I hope
that uh even if you shovel [ __ ] for a
living I just want you to be the best
guy out of that [ __ ] job that [ __ ]
shall be the best [ __ ] job but she said
in Spanish you know what she said to me
she goes what I'm telling you is gonna
stay with you for the rest of your life
as a man to be a man you have to tell
people what time you gonna be there and
I'll never forget ten days later as I'm
calling the ambulance she's on the floor
[ __ ] dead I'm sitting there thinking
she was saying goodbye to me she was
telling she was reading me the riot act
of 1968 that was the right that's the
riot act that you parents how old was
your father when he passed 37 I mean how
old were you I'm sorry you were three so
I was damaged goods
mmm once he died I'll do it I was just
trying to put the pieces together and
once my mother died I was damaged good
but that broke down the central nervous
system belief system yeah the little
Catholic system I had belief in my head
that broke it down because what God
takes away a mother yeah once you take
that belief away from somebody anything
is possible what did I mean do I mean
we've talked about this before though
but you know and just in private
conversations you know I mean look
everybody you got to twist yourself up
every now and then but at the same time
you know you did man you came out
[ __ ] great because you could you're a
good dude it's I mean and I try to
explain to people that sometimes you
know you you know it sounds crazy Lee
but sometimes you don't know right
you think you don't really like I didn't
think stealing was wrong for a long time
no I knew it would like otherwise decide
if I robbed you I'm a piece of [ __ ] but
if I rob like Nordstrom who [ __ ]
cares is a [ __ ] right yeah you know you
have this weird value system that you
create but as a kid I mean but it's with
a young mind especially you don't have a
father like for me I found that like you
create what you think a man is at a
young age right and then uh and it's
stupid [ __ ] a man should be able to
fight [ __ ] a lot of women get you know
be good in sports and you create this
image of what you think it is and then
at about 25 26 you start to realize
that's not what a man is and you spend
like the next 15 years trying to break
all these [ __ ] bad habits you created
for yourself you know and and like I was
always taught to swing first now it's a
practical thing for us if a guy's
warfare mouthing off to you just [ __ ]
hit him don't don't hesitate just if we
thought about it you [ __ ] up that was
my mother's rule just hit you up in a
sad day I think I might have that yeah
oh you commit that's it you hit them or
and or whatever you got on you you hit
them with it and just and now now that's
not a practical way to as an adult you
know but you learn that from from other
people that you know and and that just
sticks with you so it's always swing
first [ __ ] it just if we're in we're in
if I'm gonna get jump take one with you
you know what I mean and I but trust me
I'm not trying to be a tough guy chalked
up many a now it's like I said in my
special I don't know how many fights
I've been in but I've got about 19
strong losses [ __ ] epic you know
punches through the head but but I'm
saying there's other ways to handle
situations that you you don't you and
you just think that's the only way to do
it if a guy's running his mouth about
you then you need to confront that
because for some unknown reason your
reputation you know and then you just
think this way even though like I'll be
honest with you every time I went out
with my friends I was nervous I was net
I used to play cool but I always had
like those butterflies in my stomach
because I knew that you know if you
would some kids you know some [ __ ]
eventually is gonna happen but you went
out anyways when you know because these
are your friends and this is what you do
you know what I mean
but you don't make those
decisions as a young mind that's what
I'm trying to tell you so you get you
get you get caught up and [ __ ] but
you're still a kid like I always say
what I if I was talking to myself at
this age you know or if I [ __ ] up or
did something and I said to myself at 17
you know what do you don't you know yeah
I wouldn't you you you you you view
yourself as a kid with the mind you have
now but that mind is not fully developed
especially if you got all that [ __ ]
going on
I found an old email I just turned into
dr. Phil no no this is what this is what
the church is about brother Lee are you
not much no no church is about this the
church is about letting people as people
don't know you know I found a little
email last week troublesome email of a
friend a dear friend at one time and
life took over you know and you know
life when you love somebody you never
stop loving that there's certain people
you are animus I never stopped loving
this guy but the bridge that was created
between us was just a heavy bridge and
if I try to talk to him I'm gonna have a
nervous breakdown at this age so we keep
it very light but he did send me a
troublesome email three years ago that
he heard somebody told him on the
podcast that he heard something that I
had robbed that he was conclusive now
that he didn't believe it at first but I
had come clean about it on the podcast
and and somebody had called them and
reminded him of something and you know
and I wrote him well I say I found this
like couple nights ago but I wrote him
back like this to [ __ ] our explained
to him you know my age at that age who
the person that I was and now I could it
was great I read it two days later he's
never gotten back to me yet he started
to come back to me you know I thought he
would read it but this is how back the
pain goes between us because it's 40
[ __ ] here oh and then what he [ __ ]
me but now here's the other thing buddy
is that and the anger is what I realized
I walked around with a lot of anger
we all do but it's it's it's a little
different when cement natural [ __ ]
happens to you that doesn't normal
people don't go through and and and the
thing I found as I've gotten in you know
older is you you you you tend to act out
you put you projected in other ways like
even if I'm doing something stupid
it still stems from the fact and I'm
hurt you know because that's where all
that comes from even these people that
argue politically they're all hurt
people something hurt them that that's
why they're this way even when I'm
[ __ ] screaming at the top of my lungs
in my twenties at the calm restored even
you know even what my friends sometimes
it you you you develop patterns through
like a wounded stage if that makes any
sense that make sense so well you act
out on [ __ ] you there's so much going
through you now with that being said
it's not the other person's
responsibility that you you may have
wrong to understand that you don't I
mean because now you're a cause of
something to them if that makes any
sense
oh I don't one of the reasons this is
how high even at that age I adored him
but I had to stop being his friend
because I wasn't doing him any favors
right like at that age at the age of
twenty people it was a very painful
thing for me to be around them because I
had done him wrong well there's this I
know I've been wrong he did know but he
didn't have it known and then you came
clean that you did do it no no no no I
knew even at that age I had done him
loan he had done a big favor for me you
know last week was uh I was starting to
tell Rogan on his podcast that last
Saturday it was myit the second family I
live with the mother's 80th birthday
party and they had a big thing in Philly
and I couldn't go cuz had someone they
won't able to take a 6:00 a.m. flight
somebody would have to pick me up in
Philly but I got you know that's not a
normal statement what's that the second
family you live what can you believe
this right but but I'm saying like as a
normal person when people say that you
it's just a part of who you are it's a
natural its mother died I moved in with
the Bender's they stay with them but I'm
saying
second that the fact that you have to
you have to preface the second 16 months
over the benders yeah then the week that
Reagan got shot they asked me to leave I
mean I was out of control
and I'm really mad at them and like
three months before I was asked to leave
I was hanging out with this kid we would
bunk better he was nuts
I loved him he was another nut drugs
called whatever we robbed [ __ ] and he
came to me like I was telling them I owe
the benders are gonna throw me out any
Dana I just a matter of time
I got all Mia now let me ask you this
question when you when you were doing
all that [ __ ] you knew they were gonna
throw you out but you kept doing it was
it kind of like a self-destructive thing
or you just you just didn't care or you
just were still acting out you found
what I'm saying like if you if they said
to you look Joey we're taking you in
you got to act a certain way you got to
help us help you and you were just like
[ __ ] it you you were still was there
like do you remember the the rationale
behind it or were you just a rationale
behind it was that my mother just died
right and in my mind the back of my head
I couldn't wait to pull anthony bourdain
that's how he said - waiting for anthony
bourdain situation to come up whether I
was gonna pull a gun on somebody they
were gonna shoot me what I was gonna do
too many drugs right I was at that point
it was it was suicide by circumstance
almost when I was living with that by
the way suicide by cop solutely it was
suicide like I'm gonna do something I'm
gonna go so [ __ ] hard that I'm gonna
say I'm gonna do this I don't I don't
want to do it officially but I'm gonna
I'm gonna do this you know I live by
allergies you know I believe in the
moistures of life I'm leavin I just
spoke to some buy-in this that there
were the tail end of some stuff but they
understood what was going on and and you
have to understand at that time I was I
was should I was just I was pure misery
yeah I had brought the misery that was
in my house to their house I could feel
the energy I had brought the same misery
that I had my home before my mother died
was now Adele
I could feel what I did that was causing
your toxic I was toxic
it's to top it all off I'm doing drugs
I'm going to high school I'm getting B's
I got a day job I mean you can't believe
all this [ __ ] it's not like I'm mugging
old people I got you beating them
ninety-year-old
no no no I would go to school from 7:30
to 1:00 and then I would take the bus
and work from one-thirty to five in the
lumber yard and then I'm gonna go to
benders I would eat dinner with them
like a family we talk at seven o'clock
I'd meet my buddies could get a gram a
[ __ ] blow a couple hits ass now see
no I want to ask you not quite easy
[ __ ] nips so going back to that
though like mmm and again I'm only I
don't want to make this about me I can
only really no you're saying I want you
to do so what we do like so what
happened week like as a young kid and
I'm asking you this in a question did
you create a persona did you create
something that you made you you that you
have just it's it's morphed into who you
are because there's a big difference I
remember having a very dear friend of
mine who was always into something there
was like a five six year period where
you know he got into some heavy [ __ ] and
then afterwards we were talking and he's
he's evolved and he's grown and I'm in
that five to six year period right now
love this kid so and I said oh he's like
I can't believe I used to I was that way
and I'm like no this who you are now is
who you always were you created that
that was not you but it's become a part
of you now for me I was embarrassed I
was never embarrassed but I always tried
to play tougher than I was even though I
was a scrappy kid you know what I mean
not that I was embarrassed that I was
smart but I just always tried to
downplay things not that I'm the
smartest guy no I'm just saying and I
hid my intelligence but some of the guys
I was around it wasn't hard if not be
smarter than some of them you know and
and my interest in writing and my
interest in performing but I held on to
that persona cause it was almost like a
safety thing does that make any sense so
then you you start what you start Wilin
out because that becomes disk this guy
I'm not trying to break it down I'm just
curious do you understand did you create
were you always was this always you or
did those events create somebody and I
know that Daedalus events Griz they
created somebody I was a very decent kid
I was very Catholic okay
I went to confession every week I I
would steal quarters from my mother's
bar and it would drive me [ __ ] crazy
like the roll of quarters like I would
take like four quarters from that and I
would confess that would drive me
[ __ ] crazy but let's just say I was
by the book okay so after this event you
are ready wiling out a little bit no I
was by the book it's all I have to give
her mom died in it that's what I'm asked
was by the book till I was about 13 okay
and then I always grew up around drugs
right drugs were around me yeah was
around me till coke all that [ __ ] oh you
know pills suddenly we're not around
very suddenly it wasn't for me wasn't
for me how ball wasn't for me because my
mother had a bar huh
no that [ __ ] was for me and then one dad
just said let me try this weed I liked
how it smelled and it was like a secret
it was like a big secret
I had my weed friends and add my decries
my geek friends would call me a you want
to geek out and go to Honda put it
karate uniforms - I know I'm gonna go to
brats and build the model we're gonna
press to get high it was with the what's
up with this bridge fathers going I like
sitting on the bus but I bust 15 to get
on then they give you 15 in quarters
when you get there but if dad has to
stay there all day that means we got the
house until 6:00 and he can't come home
early if he loses all his money you say
I gotta stay there for the 6 o'clock bus
so you know I was that kid but I was
always working out I was just asking
because then there's the guy that we
always we I go back to to which I talk
about in my act and in the principal's
office which I'm past that but sometimes
I find myself going back to the the guy
I was in my 20s and 30s because I find
the humor in that
how [ __ ] stupid I was sometimes or
dumb [ __ ] I did as a kid you know but
then I asked myself did I create that
guy not that I'm pretending to be that
guy
because I'm I was I became that God Oh
Brad that thing he wanted once I became
that guy yeah at 18 by by 18 those two
years without my mother told me one
thing that I was not a tough guy
I know me as a tough guy I was crazy if
we had a scrap and a gun fell from your
waist and I picked it up I blow your
[ __ ] head off
hmm because I was ready to die because I
missed my mother the pain that's that's
what it is even the hole of course is
too much
by the time a teen came [ __ ] the world
mmm [ __ ] the world bro I hung out with
dudes it you know what Brett that
pictures yours it's a nice picture but
guess what Brett it's [ __ ] mine now
you had a friend that was a walk-in be
like this one what do you do about it
what [ __ ] I wasn't that person right
but if you gave me resistance I became
that person and behind me you had three
[ __ ] right you had a deal with
if you said something to me again the
question I was asking that scares me
that that Joey is scared okay and that's
always that Joey Diaz yeah the guy that
I talked about in my special I created
at six or seven if that makes any sense
no it's six of ten I believed in nuns I
believed in God I believed in Santeria
right I believed in society because the
immigrants even though all right so even
though you fought it right at three I've
believed in the flag right I believed in
the United States of America he stood
though I my mother my mother was raised
in Mena by another Hesse though hmm Cuba
mom's raised their sons at that time
paler hisses okay has he doors
hmm the surface that's how much she
loved his country even though she sold
cold numbers and [ __ ] yeah did heroin
and all that [ __ ] she believed in this
country and so did i okay but then let
me tell you what happens so my mother
dies I'm gonna get Social Security I
can't get it there's my father that
certificate was nemesis
really it was like a thousand things so
that love I had for the country I found
that it was all bureaucracy uh-huh
that's a child that's a 16 year old
child who came here
yeah miss [ __ ] money yeah so there's
a piece of paper he needs money
what is he gonna do if he doesn't have
this money he's gonna do something now
again
do you want me to look you in the eye
and tell you I had to do something to
get money though I don't I gotta get a
job
I got I got a thousand jobs I opted to
rob drug dealers like bats did but again
that's that person you're saying yeah no
I was a creature why I was a victim of
my environment yeah my saying I was a
victim no no no I get I get exactly what
you're saying
and then then I got harder and harder
and I see now in my in my professional
opinion I would say that if the drugs
weren't involved you could have had a
clearer head and and please yeah what if
the pain was bad then the drugs weren't
I wouldn't have had a crier head what
because that pain after you said that
that night on stage and when Mike last
Saturday when I called Mike to tell his
mother a happy birthday and I thought to
myself we don't well I was the Godfather
the best thing of the Godfather for me
bro since the day I watched it in the
movies cuz I hope saw The Godfather the
movie theater at the cinema theater
alright and then I bought the book you
could get the book and I bought the book
and they had the picture of the car
blown up in the book and all that [ __ ]
you know not to Sicily but the thing
that stuck my mind yeah Monday Thursday
Wednesday the thing that stuck out the
most of me about the Godfather was that
you know if he's your brother how come
you have a different name because my
brother Sonny found him one day and
brought him home and and you're sitting
there going what the [ __ ] is he talking
about and I'll never forget that going
home and like five days after that movie
I saw it I'm having dinner with my mom
and some of her friends at home mom I
talk to you my son what if I went out
one day and I met a kid that didn't have
a mom and dad can I bring them home and
she goes yeah so dog I was research
looking for a homeless kid be
cuz I wanted a brother my mother
couldn't have any other kids I was
already 12 or 10 or 11 so for like two
years I would ask like kids you you
happy yeah I got a to be old you're
trying to steal a little it was
hysterical I was like a college
recruiter though you happy with your
mother you let it poke the light way at
my house we got no curfew you understand
me you know I got this calling yeah and
fried bananas and Malta you gonna look
like this all the time kids a come
strong coffee oh my God my mom had the
bar so the first floor with tears of my
refrigerator we're [ __ ] solidus and
I'm not talking my boss I'm talking
about coke 7up I'm gonna call a [ __ ] we
need to put that in the hot dog truck
the tech soda they used to have that at
the bar my mom used to have real soda
but she knows that some people don't
give a [ __ ] so she would get the cases
of bottles 3,200 bottles and it would be
like liven up with 7up yeah the wall
they were delicious they would grape but
check was from food town was Czech soda
is a generic brand was a kinase to get
our soda and I get vanilla wafers oh my
god and dip them in the iris how long
but when you're looking for that kid you
didn't realize one day you were gonna be
that can you [ __ ] believe that
right so for three years I almost had
Michael Olsen moving Michael Olsen I got
him convinced smokeless cigarettes is
either seven listen to me why I don't
know I don't know why I don't know her
last questions me I just know he needed
help because he had never gotten to the
dentist so when his teeth came out when
he was six he started smoking right over
him and he had his cavities was so bad
he's on Facebook now grinning like liked
it like a [ __ ] Liberace fresh teeth
yeah you got those fresh tea caps and
pro his cavities were so bad that he
could put a cigarette in his front tooth
and it was the tooth was here dug the
cavity was up here and he could put the
cigarette in the hole that's how bad his
teeth were his breath from six feet away
smelt like a dead [ __ ] body's a stock
and Isis look at them and go you know
what this kid just needs a house this
kid just needs a little supervision
you know what why he gotta pick the
hardest one
because you got everything gotta sleep
next to this [ __ ] guy I'd send them
up to the attic like Norris here's the
house I would bring them all when they
eat I had a great liver that's my
brother he's up in the attic a stereo
where's teeth you've ever seen a great
living room I had everything I perfect
house for a kid I had my own bedroom and
garage
yeah the bedroom down there they wanted
a moving down I had like nine bedrooms
in that [ __ ] house I'm giving that
Terrace and it's weird I became that kid
hmm and then Italians opened that door
to me yeah
but I still say to myself you know like
I so I got thrown out well let me ask
you this question guys imagine you see a
kid now going through what you're going
through as a 55 year old man and not
even having to go through that so that
there's no relation there's nowhere you
can empathize you just see a kid [ __ ]
14 years old or 15 no parents bouncing
around from couch to couch or whatever
right now imagine that that's now
imagine looking at that kid and seeing
the anger and seeing the sadness and all
that [ __ ]
mmm if if you've already come to terms
which [ __ ] you've done in the past then
that's even better but if you haven't
I'm not saying you have her habit now
that's that kid that did all that and as
a 55 year old man if you're sitting
there with a 14 year old kidding you
found out or even a teen you found that
all this [ __ ] that he did you're gonna
look at him you're not gonna be like
this is a rotten kid you're gonna be
like we're hopeful let me talk to him
let me let me help this person let me
focus
so when you have that the only reason
why I'm saying that when you have that
inner vessel I see that anger yeah first
of all you can't beat that anger the
anger has to wear off on its own mm-hmm
the anger that's why low testosterone
was the greatest thing ever
yellowbook horny Adams has a great bit
about that but got an 18 year old angry
kid yeah again that's the most dangerous
person he could talk to on the world he
thinks he doesn't really can't see
passes knows that's a mother from your
father
yeah of course the father stops calling
all of those situations destroys an 18
year old boy
or a female destroys abso-fucking-lutely
and the anger so when I talk to a child
I have to rate the anger love will
always be that I will [ __ ] tell you
that from I know it love is like a if
you want me to tell you a joke it's like
a finger in the ass love is like that if
I if I want to look at your heart and I
had to put a tube through your ass with
a camera that took an 8 an hour and a
colonoscopy yeah it's like a colonoscopy
love takes a long time now overcome
anger but it overcomes well the other
thing is that when you talk to a young
kid and this is some of the stuff when I
was young when I was in my late 20s that
I was working with kids a lot is that
that was very therapeutic for me even
the stuff or is it cathartic anyways
even the stuff that me and Steve and we
do at the Children's Hospital and stuff
um it helps I don't know man it I I
realized one day and this was just a
revelation I had whenever I was getting
angry with myself I was depressed and
you know and trust me there's a lot of
that [ __ ] you know then I was all real
this career that we've all there's so
many [ __ ] away you Allah kill you and
then we add some [ __ ] to it that angers
us so it's a lot it's you know but what
I was gonna say is whenever I was
feeling a certain way I'd go out and
twist myself up might be like I'm
[ __ ] angry I'm gonna go get drunk I'm
gonna go do something stupid then it
dawned on me why is that my [ __ ]
reaction why don't I go the other way
right when I'm feeling depressed or
angry I just go out and say [ __ ] I'm
gonna go buy two large pizzas and go
down the promenade and hand out slices
to homeless people right I don't want to
I don't want to sound like a [ __ ]
Saint
it was just it was just a reversal of
thought why was every time I was feeling
a certain way my behavior would be just
destructive to me I wouldn't never hurt
another soul it was just destructive to
me whereas on the flipside if I said to
myself well then let me let me take that
anger and do something good with it and
then I just there was through a lot of
that stuff
I started calming down how do you get to
let the people listening to this because
how old were you when you got this
clarity piece 30s okay let me tell you
what I had yeah I have a 27 year old
daughter that doesn't talk to me we
don't talk I've come to peace with him
come to terms of it but at that time
when I was 32 this is 95 94 was 31 and
32 this was eaten alive at me of course
so I would get her on Wednesdays and
Sundays and the mother would you know
it's like she could have been cool but
she would just throw salt in the wall
you know she knew always fights on my
life and she would pull up with the
boyfriend in the Range Rover and you
know they were going to dinner at
Spago's I don't know I'm just making a
run yeah I got you and I remember
walking that kid to that car and kissing
her and the kid would hug me and tell me
she loved me and I'd look at the both of
them because they were trying to cut my
legs off you know we were trying to take
this kid for me and every time I'd bend
over and kissed his kid and straighten
up and look at the both of them you and
I both know I wanted just to go on the
trunk pull out the [ __ ] gun and shoot
him both on the spot mmm but I would
force myself to go on the car I would
cry like a man mmm 32 year old man
crying not wrong with that I mean
balling tears coming out of my eyes I
would open up the ashtray that was a
joint rolled and get myself together I'd
wipe my eyes I'd [ __ ] smoked a joint
and I'd get in the car and I'd force
myself to do comedy in a country-western
bar every Wednesday you have no idea
what that was like guys you have no idea
what that was like to force yourself
from that Yin so that yang do you ever
do well when you were that's a yes
really yes that's right well my brother
the night my brother died I went off no
I didn't even talk about it I just went
on and I just said all right I gotta get
I got to do it you know but it was I
don't even remember the set I don't even
care I mean but you know you you you
work through it there's the one thing
you this is one thing I tell people you
never get over
you just get through it you never know
it's always in the back yet but the one
thing the one blessing I had was then
it's not really blessing i associated
marijuana I know it's stupid now because
my dad smoked a lot I thought it was the
reason why he killed himself so I never
smoked it because I thought I'd go crazy
and I always associated drugs we're
crazy what craziness oh yeah that's a
good way to get you so far things yeah
but I meant now that I'm older I I see
that weed is nothing and but as a young
kid and plus I grew up with some you
know the a lot of the time guys there
was a no-no you know yeah I mean I
remember you know how they call you
[ __ ]
they say to you if you're in jail rob a
bank even if you murder somebody I'll
come get you if I find out you dealin
using drugs you gonna [ __ ] rot it was
just a big it was a big thing so another
reason why I never had tattoos maybe I'm
not was totally better Cox I don't just
said that but these are the
conversations we have in to be yeah
anybody could come on here and be fine
and we could be cute me behind giggle I
have those podcast tonight I wanted to
see I wanted to talk about that joke um
I gotta say something to which I love is
that people know and this is why I love
the Internet is because the Internet is
allowing the the people that are blowing
up through the internet are the right
people and a lot of people don't know
like with you or even Tripoli I mean I
did one of his podcast we were arguing
but we're brothers or brothers we're 20
years 21 years together this is like
being in the army
right only a different shotgun and and
we've always been there for each other
even worse bad talking we could be like
I was talking about when you're talking
I'll be home when you're supposed to I
would be at the Comedy Store set ended
at midnight and next thing I know it's
3:30 we're in the [ __ ] parking lot
took a lot of samurais for most bablu
Lingus I'll give you a call this week
thank you for the box my door that
[ __ ] loves the kitty Lee said you
sent them a yardstick really appreciate
we booked I love you Bob I love you your
dad you are true church family like in
Scott Cunningham and the rest he is
Sergio tiger I got [ __ ] knotty albums
thank you
Jones Chris Tingley kooky spooky I miss
you [ __ ]
Carmen Colosimo Matteo Olivares Nicky
Santos Collin O'Sullivan my girl Deborah
Hobson I love you [ __ ] all my
heart listen as you know the South Point
is sold out this weekend and guess what
wise guys in two weeks just sold out
yeah mate don't bloom and see if we're
gonna have a Thursday night maybe a
little [ __ ] warming show you could
show up with your third wife no dog we
were a family we vowed to another you
know when I did not know you were in
Cobra doctor oh yeah I did not know and
I was so happy because finally the good
guys won hmm like well thank you
people have no idea that we know like
when Willie Barcena came on here he
still remembers going to pick up Chris
Tucker when he lived in the studio on a
towel yeah you know the kinship we're
and it's a kinship for some people for
some of us some some comets come up here
bro together jealousy bog I think it is
anger bug and they get popular and they
they want what they got not to be taken
away in my world brother we spread the
love yeah and if you're doing it right
you only competing against yourself like
I don't know why people think that
there's a limited number of chairs at
the table the tables [ __ ] infinite
it's infinite yeah whatever you bring
you bring and and and though and if
you're doing it right it takes long if
you're doing it right you know one of
the worst things that can happen to you
is if you pop too early I think it's so
hard to hear to let you started look at
it's like and I know it's probably and I
know it's definitely true but when I
don't know it's it's the there's been
such a dream sold especially like I
never thought I'd try to be like an
actual like entertainer entertainer I
thought I was always gonna be wait is it
you're a dream sold like about being a
movie star being Justin Bieber and being
discovered at 13 and that being a milli
like I'm saying is that is that your
perception or is that there's somebody
tell you that's how it happens I mean
yeah it's probably my perception I mean
that why I never excited never taken one
acting class never
thought I'd do anything like this but
you kind of want it and it it's not you
had a good set by the way thank you I'm
here at the dojo I appreciate it I've
been I've been working out but I'm also
like I wouldn't want like I keep
thinking about a Charlie Murphy and how
he had to have mine when he had like 15
minutes yeah and like or don't headline
I can't be imagine being put in that
position you're not don't worry about it
eat that's true I shouldn't stop
worrying don't worry about nothing about
this guy oh [ __ ] do your job - he said
something before about something I
looked through my goal what do you want
with I know this is why you need to
smoke more dope and stop thinking you
have anxiety oh yeah then you live in
the future
yeah I have depression I live in the
past I have both I live in both yeah I
get a depressed when I think about my
past I don't get depressed I get I miss
parts of things yeah I missed younger
mr. ken [ __ ] I miss the camaraderie
I missed a different type of laughter
mr. Puerto Ricans and doing the barbecue
you had me [ __ ] listen listen and
like remain cautious at least my brother
he's a Puerto Rican dude but he knows in
the seventies sixties of 80s in New York
if he lived in the shitty neighborhoods
in New York City you know and he was
Porto Rican Dominican black white you
know view Irish again you've got 13
brothers and sister yeah you live in a
two-bedroom you weren't living too good
so the big thing would be to go to the
Hudson River to cool off when I was a
kid so when I was like 13 unfund on the
weekends you'd see a rise like in blacks
Porto Ricans but it was hysterical
because they'd pull up like they were
going like two [ __ ] you know it's
weird it was an education listen my
mother had money when I was growing up
hmm and I didn't like it
we've been on 205 West 88th Street but I
haven't got my godmothers
and on 45th and Broadway and those
[ __ ] slept 18 to a room they
had roaches they [ __ ] one sandwich
between eight kids but they taught me
how to shake down
they were young they taught me have a
sweep and take garbage out when I was
around you I wouldn't tell them because
I had a TV in HBO and then I had my own
[ __ ] home conditioner in my room I
wouldn't even talk about that stuff
I'd wear the sneakers they wore and the
whole writing just to experience with
ever gone through do you know I don't
even know what the purpose of this thing
is but yeah I still remember those kids
saying to me like were you doing this
weekend my uncle uncle Vinnie's gonna
borrow a car from Charlie and we're
gonna go over to Jersey the Hudson River
and swim it's our big day yeah gone wait
is there a lament about some River and
ain't no bleep [ __ ] day this Lounge
Lizards
I don't know if they were fishing all
the time one time I thought they were
the kid they might ask all these and
this other kid we went fishing
oh the Lopez brothers the Lopez brothers
had a mom who was dying from cancer and
she would get strong pills
f66 don't even make him no more they
were like stronger than oxycontin
if she would get like 60 or over a month
and the mothers like I want to die
anyway sell them so they would sell
those pills for like 20 bucks and you
would get [ __ ] up I forget what they
were called but the brothers are crazy
these two brothers only went downhill
when they the Hudson River and they were
fishing I didn't know how to they gave
me a Paul I just finished I was just
happy they invited me we're drinking
some beers were smoking pot one it will
call a Neil well white dudes calling me
and god he thought he quote like Allah
[ __ ] if he was Italian that's going
in the top dog he thought it was a lob
cut it up for Christmas he thought it
was a lobster you he'd come up and put
on the grill
like not but he's eating his Hudson
grill oh there's no way you're supposed
to eat eel for the dog he ate the
[ __ ] heart right in front of us is
like I eat these things all the time
he's over the carpet by himself fish in
the house
dog he would eat those eels everything
whatever he would catch I mean he was
catching fishes with one eye
you know was lodged sin in 1978 do you
have any ID looking body what's that
thing in that [ __ ] people this all
the time
the New York in the 70s America it was
ten a thousand times worse than it is no
P I'm Philly was filled which also is
why I'm always defending Millennials I
mean granted they're a little soft but
at the same time I mean dude it was we
were on my generation hasn't done [ __ ] I
mean either were and no baby boomers is
like come on what are you on your third
[ __ ] marriage you know
thanks for cocaine what's a baby boomer
be like no twenty years old you're a
tweener you're between or you're between
me and my parents generation so you're a
tweener cuz you're not you're not old
enough to be my father I just got a
Denny's you better lighten up with that
shot get my disc under Denny's I gotta
say you're like you're like in between a
baby boomer and Generation X and then
there's them in between x and y but like
every generation after World War two I
think the throat was was World War 2 was
baby boomer and they came home and but
you had babies yeah they're babies
babies how old would your mother be
tonight cuz that'll tell you your mom
might have been a baby boomer I think no
I think she's a little older than that
my mom would have been 88 oh okay so
she's in between World War 2 in Korea
generation it's crazy right
1925 where the [ __ ] does time go job we
would say when I met you in early 40s
right yeah the young and Annette well
listen when I was born I was 31 it's
like [ __ ] late like I went from being
15 to being rain is it so weird
like there's no pictures of me but I
remember being like uh uh being 16 and
awesome my mother died like aging five
years question I remember going oh my
god loaders how's she going you didn't
have this two years ago what happened to
you you used to be such a nice looking
little young boy like I went from being
a sixteen to thirty so yeah I remember
there's a picture you posted when you
were you were dancing okay and that's
that spirit and in the
bad [ __ ] happens to you but that thing
is it always comes out my mom used to
say that about me she goes you you got
in trouble but you weren't a bad kid
what you know that's every mom would say
that but but I was always there's things
that happen to you that kind of [ __ ] you
up a little and you get sad all the time
I remember being sad but then there was
always that playful kid that would come
out but see I move fifteen times man I
went to 15 different [ __ ] schools so
I was always trying to make friends like
I was always the new kid it would always
start the same in front of the class you
see the kids they try you out on the
playground you gonna have to throw hands
maybe the first two weeks then everybody
becomes your friend and the next thing
you know we had a moving in so I was
back and forth from Jersey to Florida
even in West Virginia we live for a
minute you know and and it just and then
the other thing too is like this [ __ ]
that I remember I mean it just comes up
when you get older and you go how the
[ __ ] how was that normal
you know like you ever think of
something in your childhood and you want
to really think about it but you know
what's gonna take you to a dark place
and you know my father when he got
arrested in front of me not gonna [ __ ]
even thinkin well I remember he went to
the basement and there's a thing I had
and he was hiding in the basement and
the cops came and my godfather came and
then you know they're like you know
don't put handcuffs on him and I just
from that and I remember it but I didn't
remember it as a kid
I remember it when I said I'll tell you
something where I started getting real
[ __ ] I started writing a book and
writing this book was the worst [ __ ]
thing I couldn't horrible it's like I am
longer right now I stopped for two weeks
I almost killed people I almost killed
him I stopped and and I go you know why
cuz there's no [ __ ] happy ending and
I don't write off to the sunset you know
and and on top of that I don't need to
remember all this [ __ ] and that's when I
decide to stop looking in a [ __ ]
rearview man I want to write the book
over 101 purpose that really bothers me
that really bothers me I was telling Lee
today
the reason why I want to write this book
the reason why I haven't given up his
because I really want people know where
I was mentally yeah every once in a
while I remember and it scares the [ __ ]
out but the church is that vehicle to
know for you right well I want people to
know that you could be at one place
mentally and end up in a different life
changes on a [ __ ] dime on a dime and
any other words not to work on it yes
you got the work I can't sit around I
worked on this you got a work I worked
on that being jealous
I worked I'm not living my Cuban
machismo getting away yeah I worked on
working on a don't disrespect who the
[ __ ] are you to call me that you know I
had to work on those things I really had
to work on those things you have to
think about how many times like we had
this conversation one time Leanna you
have to go home with time and write down
what it takes to be Brenner's every day
the patient's well they have self
understanding everybody has blind spots
and and to really assess yourself
honestly and and either take 50%
accountability or a hundred percent to
where you're at and and with that being
said you know you you look at you just
when you assess yourself honestly and
and the thing like you you need to know
what like I needed help I didn't know
how to ask for help
I was always guide just did not into it
I thought it was weak you been need help
but you don't want a [ __ ] yeah that's
the work when you need help and you
don't want it though it is horrible you
know it's [ __ ] hard I got myself in a
[ __ ] hole horrible bad hole and and
and I I just never told anybody and and
I just had to get out of it and I try to
figure out a way and it just got
overwhelming that I had to pull somebody
I've only talked to two people my whole
life and and I pull them aside and I
said this is where I'm at and he would
have see he almost smacked me for not
coming to him ten years ago you know and
and five years ago but the point is is
that when you assess that stuff here's
something somebody said to me
that always stuck me a good friend of
mine his kid Darrell the monetary Lamont
Ray he was a comic for a while but he's
just brilliant somebody there's still
shooting off fireworks he said destiny
is persistent and that always stuck with
me and then I then I came up with this
right or wrong decisions and I always
say there's not right decisions is just
there's not right or wrong there's right
and long so taking that thing to
destinies persist and say if I'm
supposed to be here and I make a left it
may take me off my course but then
destiny will correct itself right and
I'll put you back where you're supposed
to be it may be a longer [ __ ] route
but eventually like I'm supposed to be
here even if I did something [ __ ] up
but then I that's why I stopped taking
putting so much emphasis on the
decisions you know as long as my heart's
in the right place and I'm trying to do
the right thing and if the decision
doesn't go that way then it doesn't go
that way but if it takes me off my
course eventually it'll fix itself if
that makes any sense
the Comley journey it's not only that's
all we it's [ __ ] long it's not even
about the stage journey it's about your
own mental journey I mean you're I know
you as a young man you've grown up to be
only my twenties you've grown up to be a
man you're responsible you're your in
this game you know you figured it out I
can't know these [ __ ] people can blow
smoke up your ass huh you're on the
course now that you only you could get
off but you have what I have
okay and what that is is that there's
people in this business that just take
the business home on them okay we gotta
take everything and the [ __ ] business
we got to sit there and start replaying
[ __ ] that happened [ __ ] 20 years ago
that you can't [ __ ] shake you got to
sit there and [ __ ] you have all these
things that are going on and then you
got a deal with this and and you just it
just [ __ ] it's a lot man the business
alone people can't handle see I want you
I think six years Lee okay because well
you're in a different situation but I
moved out here like you I didn't [ __ ]
know anybody well I moved out for my
girl at the time but I meant I didn't
know anybody in comedy or nothing get a
job I work I work now those six years
the odds are against you when you first
start because people quit
go home but once you get past a certain
point now you start playing the odds
right once you beat the odds and you're
in it now you're in it you're committed
okay every year after that the odds
start coming in your favor because you
start playing them whether it's 20 years
21 years I mean dude not it doesn't
matter but you know there were times you
call me [ __ ] five years ago right I
need this that you can't help me with
this oh absolutely and then I'm gonna
call you now you know what I mean but
now you hung in you're done you're there
I can't believe I wake up you [ __ ]
there you beat my god I'm going I'm
never moving tower I was that guy that I
was not gonna move tower I'll stay in
Seattle I'll do what the scenes were
different then
but you back then the scenes were
different you could develop more and it
was more comedy driven but you had to be
here in New York in order to be
somewhere now it's just the opposite
those scenes are kind of [ __ ] played
out but you can be anywhere now
especially that you're established
because you've you put your time in the
Internet is the greatest Idol this is
the best time to be an artist I think
that's why I gave my special away for
free I put it out there for free you
want to give me [ __ ] Mickey Mouse
dollars because we I think we had a
similar situation in the beginning and I
just said [ __ ] it well listen by the way
go to Bret comedy calm you can watch it
for free go ahead so it's funny how I
don't need permission to exist we you'll
see this and this could bit there are so
many obstacles oh yeah there's obstacles
day.you there's personal obstacles and
there's obstacles you can't control then
there's the obstacles of people that
when you go to an open mic and you do a
show don't purposely not follow you
because they can't they can't they'll
come up with excuses while they have to
leave and they have to go up early and
these are the people that they give the
show Stern all the money to people who
don't even know how to put the
microphone in the stand correctly you
don't see this and that's a different
form of abuse that's the abuse of why am
i gettin what he's getting these are all
and then one day you stop thinking that
way these are all self-inflict
tibe Eaton's there's a question I have
for you okay okay
did the way this has helped me so again
I don't know if there's a superfluous or
not but you the way I can't I never had
anything so I didn't [ __ ] care you
don't really like if you had more than
me
everybody had more than me I don't give
a [ __ ] and give a [ __ ] so in in in that
was my question so that I think because
there's also a burden from coming from
something like if you're if you had
parents out of expectations and you got
a [ __ ] you have this time clock where
if I don't do this by this they're gonna
judge me I was very fortunate I didn't
have that I just had a mom that loved me
and said Brett do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do and be the best at what you
do right but there is that those kids
that come here that have that that come
from something that can't handle if
somebody has more than them or they feel
that they're being judged or that you
know they have that pressure alright how
many people they're those [ __ ]
[ __ ] dudes that just that's in their
nature Oh a [ __ ] ton oh come on y'all
[ __ ] talk and have money more listen to
how scary this question is how many of
these guys left and you know I had more
talent than you did that were more
naturally talented I seen more people
we've that had more natural talent than
I have and my [ __ ] and they ran on a
natural talent uh-oh looks that could
sing they could do something that I
couldn't [ __ ] do voices something
something but if you asked me eight
years ago
Who am I top five or top ten were I
would say right now America knows who
they are now and and it has no helped by
the end with the exception of Leslie
jumps I'm not watching Leslie in in the
backward like she got on satin I live
well I guess Rogan - Rogan was already
kind of known but like Sebastian
you [ __ ] not vo vo starting to get
get um starting to blow up the internet
knows who he is now you know Bilborough
is always my number one you guys are but
you guys were in my top five but we have
the older brother thing too for you you
know and even with Joe Bill burr made me
laugh
[ __ ] frightfully laughs you know
what's great about burr is that he's
he's the perfect combination of of
writing and you know who he is it's like
a perfect storm but there was a night
the other night at The Comedy Store I
had to go on earlier it's just like
months ago
I think Argus opened and then it was
like spayed and then he brought up Rogan
no no Rogan brought you up it went BRR
me Rogan and then you and the place was
sold out and I just remember watching
him [ __ ] set when you said you you
ate or [ __ ] as out of Mashti so was
your mom told you got to eat the chow at
you lady throws and we were and we were
in the back and the place was packed and
it was like a [ __ ] I saw everybody
set obviously but my own so I stepped
back I watched some of Joe's went out of
the room came back it was like a [ __ ]
concert it was like heart and nobody
left and it was just like and I'm like
this is this is stand-up it's not a
notebook on the stage with your [ __ ]
thoughts it's not a PSA it's not looking
for the clap there it was just raw real
or uh opinionated I mean opinionated
unapologetic and it was just and I
remember sitting in the back with the
door guys and just sitting there going
and you feel inspired that's what good
comedy does it's not like if you're if
you're a you you don't look at somebody
go I got to be better than them
it's they make me work hard they they
make me want to be better
does that make any sense yes no I love
getting high and going through the store
and sit in the back and watching five
six comics in a row and not getting up I
hate when somebody's just next I mean I
gotta talk to them I [ __ ] hate it
yeah I love sitting in the dark and
letting your body just crinkle and you
got that water and you're just watching
and you're giggling and you're watching
you and Ali Wong and run ye though
D'Elia and then it's like a roll it's
like a six comic role I got enough to
sit through six I'm not gonna let nobody
which is I cut out that's enough I don't
watch people's specials I got to be
honest we go
yeah I want to watch it live i watch
everybody for me and then somebody who
follow me or like if you're on
Holtzman I'll run in you know Sebastian
I watch but you know he's my best friend
so wait we hang out I always watch Brad
was watching on Tuesday nights and see
what the [ __ ] you get back to you okay
so you gotta ask yourself what what are
you what are you trying to say and and
you're not really gonna figure that out
yet not four years in I'm only six
months in oh yeah what am I talking
about
but it's a you got a long time ago know
this take your time it's having sex the
first time you have sex you just sit
there you do missionary you come you're
like oh I want to do it again right you
don't really get good at it until you
you develop your own style your own
rhythm and it's only through
experimenting you know you need to do
two knows how long have you been doing
Carly right now 21 years okay so when
Lee explained to him when he comes to
you and I got my master's degree at the
Comedy Store if he tells you like what
he went through last night like you
don't even need to know the story you
know it's it's the funniest thing we've
already been there we've seen all this
[ __ ] we're like yeah it's so funny that
we'll have discussions and I mean he's
seen a lot I like like how Illinois like
what Eleanor's going hmm I don't know
ass at that for 15 years and watch 2014
careers blow up and then she said you
know what I could do this I could do
this I'm gonna become a comic and now
you see you're on [ __ ] Marc Maron
yes and it's inspiring to watch
absolutely I thought we literally sat
there for five years and he watched
negatives and positives he would go on
dates and go to the store with his
girlfriend and watch comics we Henry
hell you through the kitchen yeah kids
get a room you two
they got a room you're always here but
it's just funny but you guys they they
watch it they study it he's been
watching stand-up he was 15 mm-hmm he
loves younger than that you know but at
the same time the only way you can
experience it is by experience in it oh
and there's nothing you could [ __ ]
see or do that comes short to anything
we've seen
not well that's why I have been doing as
many mics as I can because I never
because you were saying good comedy
inspires you it also it does and this
side because there's a difference
between bombing and bad comedy I think
and sometimes when I see cuz I go to
open mics I'll see bad stand-up kit and
that inspired cuz I don't want anyone to
think oh he's just getting away can I
say one thing to get to bec with that
point ok good comedy can only inspire
you when you're at a certain point okay
when you know how it inspired you does
that make any sense like in other words
when you're 6 years old and you're
watching dr. J play basketball you're
Michael Jordan or LeBron James right
you're like wow I want to play
basketball and even in Little League you
still don't know what it's like you're
playing the game but you just want to be
there it's once you get in the league
and you really fully understand what
you're doing and how the game is played
is when those guys you really see what
makes them great one of my favorite
movies is Amadeus right and when so
Larry's listening to Mozart he's he just
is so frustrated because everybody is
clapping right and they don't hear the
brilliance that he hears with that
trained ear and once that ear is trained
as a comic I can listen to somebody do a
joke in the audience not respond to it
and you go that's [ __ ] brilliant how
do they not see that you're nuances the
[ __ ] you throw out that are like little
time bombs but you'll say something that
it's just naturally you write and then
like I don't get sick I eat a sigh
slamming oh that's that [ __ ] just
that resonates through the crown and and
you're hearing it with a different ear
where you're at right now you're
listening to bad comedy you see I don't
need to do bars I got everything I got I
have a [ __ ] bar I don't need to
connect with an all I do all that now
it's it's a different thing for me
watching bad comedy can inspire you
which is where you're at now right yeah
I mean I'm 90% he's comics I'm gonna be
awful well it's weird because it's that
way if we're gonna go with the analogy
you just said about sports right I think
maybe because I've been a little Joey
for 6 or 7 years but six years on the
podcast
I feel like maybe I was in high school
maybe that's where maybe eighth grade
ninth grade what do you mean if I get
like if you're if you're in the major
leagues right let's I'm like a ninth
grade freshman Lee freshman team
baseball player
I mean I'm six months in I should be six
month now you're the peewee peewee just
cuz you hang out with [ __ ] night yeah
you're a little daring cable Babe Ruth
doesn't make my ancient baseball no
getting you're getting this guy should
hang out with Ty Cobb so my people
you're you're a [ __ ] peewee football
player right now you are they had a
block now this is a good thing but it
also could be detrimental yeah
absolutely
guys like tall just slow down slow to
[ __ ] down slowly can't you can't
I told me he was booked in a row
Michael's not just get the fundamentals
from yeah yeah you know I don't like
Tommy here in the beginning it makes
something too much calmly where I
started you don't even get a head shot
you just go on stage and you just gotta
get up just gonna keep here you need
Boston his knowledge which it ain't what
you think you know the twenty minutes
don't do abortion jokes all right you
ready going through this phase you know
you're at 25 right 27 27 28 28 July
because you started in in the almost mid
boom I started at the end so the way you
guys came up because when we were at the
store and it's funny too
I was listening to Bert's podcast and
some woman some girl was saying how like
the Comedy Store um should give it's
it's white male should give their spots
up to women or whatever it was some
[ __ ] crazy interview but I remember
thinking four years ago they wouldn't
even be talking about the Comedy Store
know nobody was there
no five year we was just us in the back
well before before you guys left after
the whole Carlos thing before that there
was nobody [ __ ] there no and we do
get a set at 11:30 in the morning in
front of five people or even better yet
1:15 after Eddie Griffin just did four
hours and you got to entertain three
people that you know what melts makes
the comments were great
there's no [ __ ] MC
so if I do well and I bring you up you
gotta follow that or I got a fellowship
pal or I got a far I got a follow rogue
in and Rogen's got a follow bird there's
nobody going hey guys you know let me do
two minutes and bring up the next comic
it's just [ __ ] one after another
after another and if the person bombs
you got to figure out to get out of it
if they kill you got to figure out a
ride the wave if it's somebody famous
and the half the audience gets up to get
the [ __ ] autograph you got to figure
out how to [ __ ] and and it's this
little like sam triply says it's like
trying to put and listen you know crack
is safe and after a while you start
seeing all these different scenarios and
then then you're like I can [ __ ]
handle anywhere any place and that's it
any time throw me anyway 27 years 28
years any place I can handle any [ __ ]
scenario you know I've done Craig
Colorado where the audience is 80 feet
away and there's a fence up you know I
don't you know Sebastian talks in his
book when me and him had to do this
[ __ ] gig in a boxing ring and [ __ ]
Modesto the point is you need at least
10,000 of those do you guys ever see the
Tom Cruise movie where like he kept kind
of like Groundhog's Day but he was in a
war yeah yeah yeah he kept he kept
repeating it he kept repeating he'd I
think it's called three to one repeat or
something like that it was spitting all
over the farm crew there's always decent
but he keep by the end of it he knew
everything he would he had his master
but he had to go through it each day
again and again and again and he would
just learn one little thing and yeah I
was a good analogy I'm not trying to say
that I'm I know anything I'm just saying
like I I haven't I've gotten to see what
good and great comedy is and now I'm
back there so I I feel like I have sort
of like a cheat sheet that some people
don't have I don't know what it is but
I'm saying that could hinder your growth
absolutely the cheat sheet is they got a
work
that's the cheat sheet out of all the
people have come in here we've all had
the only people I bring on here are hard
workers that's one thing I've never
brought up fluff in here I don't believe
in fluff I don't believe in smoke and
mirrors I believe and I see people
that's my next question cuz I'm saying I
gravitate I granted guys like us like
you
a blue-collar high could be another
running it under your [ __ ] shortcuts
I don't like shortcut people they bother
the [ __ ] out of me
you know why cuz three years I did
shortcuts they got me nowhere there's no
shortcuts the other thing I had a
problem with is I had a poor kids
mentality at a point where I was okay
with it you know I'm okay with [ __ ]
alright I'll go up you know I'll show
like that type of [ __ ] there is a mint
there there is a thing too when I
started hanging out with people more
successful than me I sought rating them
that they had that I didn't and that was
thinking giving yourself value more you
know because again if somebody had
something I would always back I don't
care I don't give a [ __ ] I used to walk
around with the generic sneakers I used
to get in fights all the time
I remember my mama said my I wanted I
need a pair of Nikes my life depends on
it then I didn't then I didn't know
somebody's gonna try and Rob them but
but I'm saying like you know I'm always
fighting these kids and make Weesa
called Bobo's you know like no-name
sneakers and [ __ ] Bobo's cat heads they
were called and I just think you slipped
the slide taking me back to Panther
pride they're so fine that's what it
costs 2.99 yeah it gets [ __ ] crazy
when you're a kid it's it's everything
anyways get teased but when I was around
successful people there was a mentality
that they had like like you know where
they're like this is what I deserve and
I'll expect nothing less like for me if
a guy said to me okay I stopped doing
this I used to say yes to everything
because I'm like wonder [ __ ] am I gonna
work again I need this so we're not
gonna we're gonna put you up here and
I'm like fine I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
sleep in the car you're on I mean and I
just found that that was attracting once
I stopped that I started getting better
thanks once I'm like you know what no
I'm one of the best in the business
there you know most respect that I
should say amongst my peers you know
granted I'm you know whatever I deserve
this and if I don't get this [ __ ] you
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] your room and then
they'd come back okay and I just
realized that there was a lot of thing
that I was saying yes to I did it I did
the dog like I beat up for it
six or seven years longer than what I
should I got beat up yeah
cuz that's all I still remember asking
somebody wants
and they told the friend of mine that
Jodi is getting a little bit too big for
his britches about 10 years ago because
they play the trick on me they conned me
to go up there for a certain amount of
money and then when I got up I was the
headliner and I was taking pictures with
people all this [ __ ] from The Longest
Yard and I'm like man we really want to
do it again but like well this time we
got up the status a little bit he goes
oh no no I know that is it's always
gonna stay at - honey I know exactly the
[ __ ] that I said I'm not [ __ ] doing
it I'll tell you how fair that is he
told somebody goes I think jugged is his
head's getting a little bit too big
no you got a hassle what you work for
this is what I'm doing this is the work
I do what two things changed me doing
comedy in the Middle East and when I was
given a one night before Thanksgiving I
was able to keep the door and I saw what
I made in that one night and I'm like
what the [ __ ] yeah you realize I won't
live in robbing you for well yeah but
then but it is a look it's a symbiotic
relationship I need the venue you know
but then I started doing my own little
offshoots and just keeping everything
right and you're like okay there's now
like now I can [ __ ] live like a
person
listen we saw Stanhope do it doggy doggy
he's always been he's always been ahead
of the game he's always been when the
car you know when he told the guy in
Columbus about his [ __ ] son remember
that this all started in a funny bone
with him and John rouse just cause to
havoc and rest in peace and rest in
peace
they caused havoc at a funny bone and
[ __ ] Stan at the Shawn rouse that
consult with the dude stand up well up
there is something to do it again and
the dude band stanhope of all the funny
bones hmm who once tried to I forget the
guys name and they tried to ban him then
he had his balls shaved in Austin so he
was shaved from that he was banned from
that Club here's ball-shaped on stage
yep
he got a girl to shave his balls on
stage okay and then they got banned from
Austin and a couple other clubs said we
don't need that no wives and then he
went to Ohio one of those clubs somebody
not cleave of not Columbus I forget what
the guy's name was and he went to his
club and the guy had a small man
and he's got a kid that's got problems
like some type of physics that to me
that's that's off-limits
so but Stanhope didn't give a [ __ ] but
yeah shown Ralph look the Hammond went
off and then something happened the guy
insulted Stanhope and Stanhope said
something to him about the kid so the
guy want to have to stand hope and tried
too bad I never that's crazy
I met more about how he started doing
the bars and yeah well Stan Polk's ain't
going up to Montreal and crashing him
yeah well stand up said you want to ban
me okay I'll call the club across the
street from you and I'll do a [ __ ]
100 percent door deal he was doing that
Tammy I'm ever going to see him in
Hollywood it was Rogen I'm [ __ ]
Hollywood and some dump dump mm-hmm and
he had [ __ ] 700 people in that dump
standing up yelling throwing beer
bottles [ __ ]
yeah me and Rogan walked out like that
was [ __ ] up but he was [ __ ]
Calculus making a [ __ ] all the way the
[ __ ] Bank it's crazy it's crazy well
let's see but what I'm saying though
where you're at now you're you guys like
yes you you guys are finally I was
saying this the other day Joe Rogan and
Chelsea Handler did more for comedians
than any of the late-night talk shows
then in in in in that's a true [ __ ] his
face except I mean if you count Chelsea
as a talk show
but what Joe is done for people is
amazing
and what Chelsea did for the people on
her show think about that think about
all the people that we know that we're
able to come off on that I we won yeah
and Josh wolf cap even though I know you
guys have a beef um which I had found
out about that I want to talk about that
but who else but leuco Rogan did food
for everybody man but this would but
because they they have this they have
this think because the comics you need a
stick you need a road stink you need
something to you that you look at
another comic and be like okay I see the
miles in your eyes this guy this this is
a comic and that's the other thing we
don't play that male-female [ __ ] at the
Comedy Store
yeah yeah I always hear people talk that
it's like I don't look at them I don't
[ __ ] none of us
all of our all the girls that perform
there are [ __ ] once one thing I do
want to stress that there's a mild
misconception about podcasters that
people think because you go on Rogan
your life is gonna change no not at all
no you have to cover the spread you have
to be able to still do the things that
you do every day every [ __ ] single
day it's like when you pop this show
while you were shooting the first couple
episodes did you think this is gonna go
anywhere no you did it I just this is a
job I'm a 20 year veteran I'm just I
hope this goes well I've been here
before I've had a lot of troubles and
look and now you're going back for a
second season hopefully yeah hopefully
yeah whatever who knows who the [ __ ]
knows but but you do know that we get to
a point to where it's we you come out
like this and then then you like this
and then you like this and then you're
just like all right just whatever it is
I know I'm uh
I hope they caught that on the video but
you get come out wide-eyed then you get
a little angry then you get a little
like [ __ ] it and then you get normal
when it gets to Germany oh it's not
affordable
I love it a beautiful if you don't fool
German in the beginning that I would be
here and that I would have been at the
con restore and that was the one thing I
had it being at Mitzi's thing is looking
at being a part of that history and to
me my history is with you
Rogen's event you know when it was on
the ropes and let's be honest I mean we
[ __ ] we we help bring that place back
and with between Merrin and rogue and
always talking about on the podcast and
people were like let's see let's see the
[ __ ] Zoo and you got and you as well
and then all these people came and that
this is see they can't control what they
think comedy is they can control what
they want to put out there but the
Internet allows people to see you
because let's be honest a lot of our
comedy if we were playing by their rules
no no don't we they would just keep in
the back this person has to say this
this this this we're doing that you know
we need to push this this this and now
people could be like oh did you see so
and so on oh really let me pull this guy
for you look at bill burr [ __ ] [ __ ]
on Philadelphia you know what do you
think people do from the line our window
used to be from 8:00 to 10:00 at night
no late-night talk show
no more no more I want 6 a.m. to 6 p.m.
[ __ ] I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
I'm hopping it good it you came I'm
happy I saw you a few weeks ago I'm
happy for your success if you haven't
seen Brandon [ __ ] Cobra Kai you
listen up
it's amazing the other day when I heard
about it I could lie to both you guys I
had a feeling really I had a feeling
because America's looking for that
nostalgia this TV is not working this
diversity my neighbors gay TV yeah it's
not working it's not 8 to 10 o'clock
this times I'm reading my daughter a
book and I don't see the word stupid I
don't want to hear that word anymore in
kids books I don't want to hear I see
some Disney shows that say some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] I grew up on family affair I
grew up on the walls I grew up in a
different American type of TV and they
gotta bring that back from 8:00 to 10:00
I go lose it but you said you knew
because of the nostalgia thing I had a
funny feeling see I read it I have a
funny feeling when I read it I when at
first I was nervous cuz you saw the
fanboys on on line one to hate it you
know what they hit everything everything
one say but let me tell you some couple
years ago I did a movie with the Cobra
Kai teacher and Johnny the blonde yeah
ask him what Dean Cain movie me Dean
Cain and those guys we did the in fact
they had a karate school at in the
valley so it was like a fake god it's
crazy it's the dog that saved one of
those the last one I did
why dress up like a woman if the two
guys from the Karate Kid or not the
brunette the blonde and Billy Zabka yeah
and the kid that was in that Rambo
yeah Cleese John John that's me my
sensei crease yeah john kreese
i grew up on that movie the same way
that you won't watch the new mechanic I
didn't see the new Karate Kid with with
Jaden Smith it's not bad
don't hate it everybody I meet 17 and I
haven't I liked it but it's not like it
doesn't give me because there was a
thing with daniel larusso's mom right
and Randy Keller aren't yet ready Heller
right and and and when they first moved
she came from Newark and uh and they
were together and I always thought that
was how my mom was hi boys
you know are those your friends and
they're like nice car mister California
but they rose all that turmoil and then
I had that relationship with my mom and
there was always our movie and then when
I got to do scenes with her I couldn't
believe brother it's way can they find
you I just if you guys want I I released
my special for free at Bret comedy calm
you can go there you can donate to own
it you can buy a t-shirt you get to
download for free
or if not just go watch it Scott won so
far just go watch it it's nice and easy
it's always comedy be ret comedy calm I
love you guys thank you thank you again
man oh it's always a pleasure to see you
my boy right and I'm glad we were [ __ ]
down and then this is like by the way
this is a kitchen conversation we had
that this is it this is we're getting
into each other trying to smother this
is it but as usual I want to thank on it
the best the best that Mexican chocolate
protein part of the new [ __ ] [ __ ]
delicious is [ __ ]
I love the shrimp export and I love the
shoe check immune immune alpha brain on
a percent money-back guarantee they only
want the product back if you don't like
it how does that who does that on it
that's who does that go to Anna calm
right now press in church BAM get 10%
off delivered right to Lacaze understand
me right to your [ __ ] crib that's how
it does it number two hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go where hiring is simple fast and
smart a place with growing businesses
connect to qualified candidates that
place is zip recruiter Tom slash Church
CH you are CH you're like Joey why do I
have to go to typically why because you
want the best qualified
out there for your job that's what
you're looking for you're looking for a
qualified candidate and it takes a long
time
not with zip recruiter you're like why
it used to be hard multiple job sites
stacks of resumes confusing review
process no more today hiring can be easy
and you could have it throw in one place
and get it done one two three with zip
recruiter dot-com / Joey why because
with the powerful matching technology
zip recruiter scans through thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job zip recruit is so effective
that 80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
are you kidding me are you kidding me
typical to send your job to over a
hundred little webs leaving job boards
but they don't stop there with results
like that it's no wonder zip recruiter
it's the highest rating hiring site in
America did you hear that
zip recruiter is the highest rating
hiring site in America so do me a favor
right now the church family you can try
the zip recruiter for free gratis who
gots nothing nothing at this exclusive
web address ready grab a pen zip recruit
comm slash Church CH you are CH that zip
recruiter comm slash Church CH you are
CH it's that easy you're looking for
somebody you want the right candidate
zip recruit comm / Joey
I want to thank slash Church I'm sorry
they've run away from me I want to thank
my man Bret I forgot to mention to if
you guys like my podcast check me out on
your on the list you can add it you can
subscribe at Bret comedy be ret comedy
calm and watch the special for free
there and check out Cobra Kai season 2
coming up your beautiful brother I love
you man love you thank you and I'll see
your [ __ ] Wednesday tip top
Magoo have a great day it's the 2nd half
grab your ball salute the flag [ __ ]
we're going deep kick that [ __ ] meal
Lisa I am